la police municipale de
voisins-le-bretonneux sera t elle à
bientôt armés le débat a été lancé par
olivia fondent au conseiller municipal
d'opposition lors du conseil municipal
du 16 février
objectif mieux protéger la population de
voisins-le-bretonneux suite aux derniers
attentats terroristes on pourrait
considérer qu effectivement
voisins-le-bretonneux est une ville sans
risque il n'y a pas de ville sans risque
actuellement on est dans un état
d'urgence
je pense d'abord à nos policiers
municipaux parce que c'est d'abord eux
qui se retrouvent face au danger c'est
pas nous les élus c'est la police
municipale qui se retrouve face aux
terroristes
le terrorisme ne choisit pas il ne
réfléchit pas deux secondes si c'est un
policier municipal ou six reprises au la
police nationale aujourd'hui les cinq
policiers municipaux de
voisins-le-bretonneux sont équipés de
bombes lacrymogènes de matraques
télescopiques de menottes et de gilet
pare balles de son côté la mairie ne
ferme pas le débat sur la question et
pour l abordé lors d'un prochain conseil
municipal
c'est un sujet qui a déjà été soulevé en
voisin il ya quelques années
le maire à l'époque avait fait une
demande à la préfecture qui a été refusé
aujourd'hui je pense que là mais de la
question mérite d'être posée
voilà ceci dit moi je suis assez mesuré
quand même sur le sujet je souhaite en
débattre avec avec tous les élus
évidemment parce que c'est pas un sujet
c'est pas un sujet anodin
ces derniers mois les communes du chéné
d'elancourt et de rambouillet ont entamé
leur police municipale